soignant à cœur ouvert documentaire que
j'ai donc réalisé avec Adrien Benoliel
accompagné accompagné par léonib BES un
film qui dit je crois toute l'envie et
toute la bonne volonté des soignants
pour bien soigner même quand les
conditions d'exercice sont difficiles on
parle souvent d'un problème de moyens
dans le monde médical est-ce seulement
une question de moyen la formation
initiale n'est-elle pas aussi un sujet
autant de questions qu'on va se poser
avec nos invité agès Buzin bienvenue à
vous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ancienne ministre de la Santé
hématologue que professeur des
universités et conseillère maître à la
Cour des comptes pierre schevob Tellier
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
infirmier aux urgences de l'hôpital
bejon à Paris membre du collectif
interurgence vous faites partie des
signataires de cette tribune dans Le
Monde nous n'avons pas choisi ce métier
pour vous faire subir cette violence et
être maltraitant Thierry zelstein
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
directeur du comité médical du groupe
MACSF mutuel qui accompagne plus d'un
million de professionnels de santé au
plus près des soignants et qui a aussi
soutenu le le le film qui ACC cru au
projet et au sujets et je précise que
vous êtes vous-même docteur en médecine
Claude rambau bienvenue vous êtes
première vice-présidente de France assos
santé qui représente la voix des usagers
du système de santé vous êtes juriste
spécialiste de la prévention des risques
liés au soins et vous militer notamment
pour une amélioration de la sécurité des
patients et la pertinence de leur prise
en charge merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
peut-être un mot d'abord du postulat de
base qui était le mien lorsque j'ai
commencé ce documentaire je trouvais que
quelque chose clochet dans ce qu'on
appelle la relation de soins que nous
patients et proches de patients n'étions
pas toujours bien traités dans le monde
médical ça était une question difficile
à soulever et je voudrais commencer à
l'aborder avec vous peut-être Claude
rambau puisque vous êtes la voix des
patients ici sur ce plateau est-ce que
vous avez vous-même fait ce genre de
constat est-ce qu'on vous remonte ce
genre d'information depuis le terrain
tous les jours dans les parce que je
suis rattachée à une association qui
lutte contre les infections nosocomiales
et pour la sécurité des patients donc
tous les tous les jours nous avons des
appels et ce matin encore j'ai une dame
qui vraiment est est caractéristique de
ce que vous évoquez là du problème de la
relation puis que voilà elle est elle
est en grande souffrance à la suite de
de de cancer du seint et de Sein et une
réparation une chirurgie réparatrice qui
a été mal faite et on lui dit maintenant
maintenant il faut aller voir un psy vos
douleurs ça relève du psy c'est c'est
très violent pour une personne de
s'entendre dire que c'est ces douleurs
relèvent de de de l'apsie le lien
l'association dont je vous parle elle
est issue des victimes de la Clinique du
Sport et au départ cétait des gens qui
avaient des c'était des personnes qui
avaient des infections graves de du
rachis à la suite de d'appara de
d'utilisation de matériel non stérilisé
et on les a toutes orienté vers des
psychiatres h donc ça c'est très violent
de ne pas reconnaître la personne dans
son besoin de soin voire dans son besoin
de réparation et et de prise en charge
de la douleur donc voilà agès Busin tout
en reconnaissant évidemment l'immense
valeur des soignants et leur sens du
sacrifice et leur force de travail
est-ce qu'il y a quand même un lien qui
s'est distendu peut-être ces dernières
années ou même avant entre les patients
d'un côté et les soignants alors je ne
crois pas parce que d'abord euh dans
votre reportage on voit bien que les
soignants réalisent euh cette difficulté
au travail et qu'ils l'expriment et
qu'ils essayent d'y remédier donc euh
cela prouve qu'il y a qu même une
empathie qui est là euh les conditions
de travail se sont dégradées ces
dernières années pour de multiples
raisons on y reviendra et ces conditions
de travail dégradé imposent des des
rythmes et une pression au soignants qui
fait que l'empathie a du mal à
s'exprimer h je pense qu'il y a
d'autres raisons qui sont aussi la
difficulté d'assumer tout au long de sa
vie de soignant h des situations
dramatiques et c'est douloureux en fait
d'être empathique à un moment prendre
sur soi cette charge mentale de la
douleur des autres peut être difficile
et ça les soignants ont du mal à
l'exprimer c'est vrai que ça n'est pas
enseigné on n'explique pas à quel point
la douleur des autres au bout de
plusieurs années de pratique peut
s'avérer être voilà difficile à à
prendre en charge ça nécessite d'avoir
du recul sur sa pratique ça nécessite un
travail
d'équipe et ça nécessite certainement
une formation préalable et bien sûr
qu'on abordera les causes précisément
les façons d' remédier précisément aussi
restons peut-être encore quelques
minutes sur le constat peut-être avec
vous les soignants pointent même un
problème dans cette tribune que vous
avez signé Pierre ch Tellier dans le
monde il y a quelques semaines nous
n'avons pas choisi ce métier pour vous
faire subir cette violence et être
maltraitant pourquoi cet appel qu'est-ce
que vous mettez derrière le mot
maltraitant ou maltraitance qu'est-ce
que vous mettez derrière tout cela il y
a plusieurs choses c'est un peu délicat
de parler comme ça de la de la
souffrance ou de la maltraitance des
professionnels si on n pas une vision un
peu élargie du du problème faut faut
bien comprendre qu'il y a une
représentation des soignants dans dans
notre pays euh il y a il y a cette
question fondamentale de qu'est-ce
qu'être un bon soignant je pense que ça
auuts de la table personne n'aura les
mêmes réponses on va être très clair
c'est une question philosophique on peut
y passer 5 heur on n'ura pas les
réponses à C question même très
subjectif bon ça dire très clairement je
peux vous dire préférez être soigné par
sœur Marie Thérèse ou docteur aous c'est
deux personnes totalement différentes
dans leur matière de de soigner mais ce
sont deux personnels soignants on va
dire si je schématise un petit peu
làdessus on a une représentation
collective notamment à l'hôpital qui est
assez qui est assez patriarcale on va
dire sur les soignants c'est si vous
êtes un homme à l'hôpital vous êtes un
médecin si vous êtes une femme vous êtes
une infirmière c'est un fonctionnement
qui représente qui est un peu dans la
représentation générale de la population
qui est largement inspiré de notre
histoire où on est un petit peu les les
descendants de de l'église et notamment
des bonnes sœurs et donc on joue
toujours ce rôle de bonne sœur euh et
c'est ça qui qui est un petit peu
handicapant pour les soignants et qui
aujourd'hui a bloqué toute une partie de
la parole des soignants pendant de
longues années c'est-à-dire c'est que
l'idée de souffrance des soignants au
travail n'existait pas on peut pas
souffrir une bonne sœur ça ne souffre
pas ça n'existe pas c'est pas que
c'était tabou c'est que ça n'existait
pas c'était donc voulaz dire que c'est
venu parasiter la relation de soi entre
le patient et so non pour l'instant
j'arrive pas à faire le lien avec le
patient dis en 2019 le collectif
inelligence a mis la main là-dessus a
dit que les soign pouvaiit souffrir au
travail que les conditions de travail
pouvaient se faire souffrir chose qui
jusque là était un tabou en plus qu'un
tabou c'était un interdit d'ailleurs
quand on l'a dit on s'est pris
directement des volet notamment du corps
médical notamment de Madame Buin qui
nous avait taxé de dévoiement du de
l'arrt maladie mais ça encore c'est
c'est c'est une posture assez classique
du médecin assez paternaliste qui vient
faire la messe à ses bonnes sœurs dans
toute cette idée là ce que je veux dire
c'est que
aujourd'hui la la question et qui
toujours la même question c'est pourquoi
y y a-t-il ces souffrances comment
est-ce qu'on PE P y répondre et
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce comment on peut
les évaluer bien euh si votre idée de de
de de duu c'est dire que c'est une
solution à la souffrance des soignants
pour répondre à ce besoin qu'ils ont de
pouvoir reprendre une communication avec
le patient je dirais qu'on n pas du tout
dedans il y a des raisons bien
évidemment endogène comme je viens de
l'expliquer sur le système qui
fonctionne à l'hôpital et qui est un peu
oppressif notamment sur les personnels
soignant féminin euh mais il y a aussi
toute une responsabilité politique de
choix et d'orientation qui ont mené
les professels soignants dans la
situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui thierelstein quand la maacsf
est sensible au sujet et accepte de
soutenir ce documentaire pourquoi parce
que c'est un sujet pour le coup qui
n'est pas tabou et et que vous avez
aussi envie de soulever parce qu'il vous
remonte du terrain de la part des
soignants eumême absolument alors nous
sommes l'assureur des professionnels de
santé vous vous l'avez bien dit nous
assurons plus d'un million de
professionnels de santé des libéraux des
Hospitaliers des paramédicaux des
médicaux donc il y a pas de pas de sujet
donc vous avez cette vue générale on a
une vue générale peti précision tous nos
administrateurs sont eux même
professionnels de santé ce qui a son
importance puisqu'on voit bien que les
sujets remontent quand vous parlez de la
souffrance des soignant on est en plein
dedans et on partage complètement ce ce
constat puisque dès 2015 nous avons
constaté que dans certains contrats
prévoyance pour pas cité donc les
garanties arrêts de travail des des
soignants euh nous avons constaté à
partir de 2015 une montée en puissance
des arrêts de travail soit pour des
phénomènes anceux des problèmes
dépressifs du burnout voilà ça a été
boosté par la crise sanitaire de de 2020
sans difficulté et de puis on est
toujours sur une une déclaration très
très forte ce qui nous a conduit à
lancer en 2022 une enquête portée par la
Fondation
mssf on a interrogé 3000 professionnels
de santé de tous horizons qui ont
répondu spontanément à ces questions et
des arguments forts qui ressort
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas pour parler très
simplement dans le dans dans notre
activité en premier pour les médicaux et
les paramédicaux ce sont les relations
avec le patient hein c'est pas le le
patient me casse les pieds au hautes
c'est je suis dans une relation qui est
qui est pas celle pour laquelle on a on
a décidé de faire médecine ou une école
d'infirmière ou une école de même ne s'y
retrouve pas dans rel même ne s'y
retrouve pas absolument qu'est-ce qu'on
met derrière le mot maltraitance claud
drambau peut-être pouvait répondre à
cette question quand on parle d'une très
longue attente aux urgences par exemple
ou oui mais oui ça c'est pas le pire on
peut on sait bien qu'on va attendre aux
urgences mais il y a effectivement une
partie de la relation mais pas seulement
vous disiez qu'est-ce qu'un soignant je
sais pas qu'est-ce qu'un soignant je
suis un peu comme vous enfin il y a
plusieurs définitions mais on peut
savoir qu'est-ce qu' un soin de qualité
par exemple d'ailleurs dans le mot soin
il dorait y avoir intégré la qualité
mais c'est un tout un soin c'est à la
fois des compétences techniques
diagnostique et mais en même temps une
qualité
relationnelle certes si on nous donne à
choisir entre quelqu'un très compétent
et qui n'a aucune relation ou quelqu'un
d'incompétent mais qui a une très bonne
relation on prendra nous qui sommes un
peu averti en tout cas on prendra les
personn compétente même si a un
caractère de chien un peu bourru et tout
ce qu'on veut hein voilà évidemment mais
la qualité d'un soin un soin de qualité
un soin qui est bien traitant pour
revenir sur et bienveillant un petit peu
différent c'est effectivement un soin
qui qui est un tout qui comprend les
deux choses pourquoi parce que même un
soin compétant s'il est dans une
mauvaise relation il peut conduire la
personne à avoir à ne pas observer
correctement son traitement ou à faire
des choses qui vont le mettre en danger
la semaine dernière je suis intervenue
dans un établissement pour une personne
qui était en suspicion d'AVC qui
attendait dans un lit son IRM pour
confirmer queil y avait ou qu'il y avait
pas et cetera et qui m'a fait appeler
parce que sa famille est adhérente dans
l'association et et parce qu'elle
voulait quitter et et signer sa sortie
parce qu'elle a donc il a fallu lui
expliquer et cetera donc si on n pas en
fait même les bonnes informations voulez
dire de la bonne communication voilà
j'ai réussi à faire cont le médecin qui
pr enge qui était pas content évidment
qu' l' cont l'extérieur mais ça ça
revient à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure et et et qui lui a donné les
bonnes informations donc voilà si on n
pas une bonne relation et
essentiellement vous avez équé la
communication on sait bien qu'on réduit
considérablement les risques qui sont
liés au soins par une bonne
communication entre
autres oui c'est global c'est un tout
agè Buin je voudrais faire appel à votre
expérience de soignante à vous est-ce
qui vous est déjà arrivé on entend dans
ce film soignants qui se confient à moi
qui me parlent de moment où on leur dit
une crise d'angoisse c'est de la merde
faut enchaîner les gardes j'ai annoncé
des diagnostics entre deux portes
parfois de façon un peu maladroite
est-ce que ça vous est arrivé à vous
alors sur effectivement dans la une
forme de
maltraitance même du corps médical
effectivement des des diagnostics dans
un couloir tout ça est connu en fait ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que toute
cette souffrance au travail elle est
ancienne à l'hôpital je l'ai connu quand
j'étais jeune chef de de clinique dans
les années 90 et on avait fait venir
exprès des psychologues qui prenaient en
charge les soignants dans les services
les obliger à parler on avait aussi des
réunions collectives pour parler des cas
des malades pour faire baisser la
pression la tenstion ce qui est
différent et ce qui est nouveau je pense
que c'est son expression publique avec
le collectif tel que mais en fait cette
souffrance elle existait déjà avant
d'accord elle est exacerbée parce que il
y a de moins en moins de so c'est un
problème là je dirais international on a
une phase très difficile à passer avec
un nombre de soignants qui globalement
est en train encore de diminuer par
rapport aux besoins de la population et
n'augmentera que dans les années 2030
probablement c'est un problème
international donc ce qu'on raconte ici
est absolument vrai dans tous les pays
du monde donc il y a un problème lié à C
manque de de personnel partout et puis
il y a un problème aussi qui est lié
probablement à plus d'impatience de la
population quand on est malade
aujourd'hui on
attend une consommation de soins
probablement
plus efficiente que ce qu'on attendait
il y a 20 ans de l'hôpital et donc il y
a une impatience qui s'exprime notamment
dans les urgences qui met de la pression
sur les soignants essayons d'approfondir
encore les causes il y a évidemment le
manque de moyens le manque de personnel
les salaires peu attractifs l'exécutif a
tenté de répondre à ses besoins encore
en août dernier Élizabeth borne la
première ministre qui a débloqué 1
milliard d'euros pour les soignants le
travail de nuit à l'hôpital revalorisé
de 25 % et le tarif des gardes augmenté
de 50 % ça c'est pour la partie j'allais
dire financière mais est-ce que c'est
seulement une question de moyen n a-t-il
pas aussi peut-être une autre question
qui est celle de la formation je
voudrais qu'on écoute Anne Levet interne
au moment du documentaire qui pointe
autre chose lors de sa soutenance de
mémoire elle pointe la formation écoutez
la rencontre avec avec l'hôpital a pas a
pas été si simple et avec la faculté
aussi puisque j'ai été confrontée bah
aux difficultés qu'on connaît de de de
l'hôpital en France en ce moment et puis
il y a eu aussi la compétition dans les
études de médecine où au début c'était
des très festif et tout ça puis
rapidement je trouve qu' a grandi un peu
une une atmosphère de compétition de
concurrence et moi j'étais pas trop
venue chercher ça enfin je pensais qu'en
faisant médecine j'aurais juste un
environnement très
bienveillant alors il se trouve que je
suis désolé moi j'ai appris quelque
chose à ce moment-là je ne savais pas
que à ce point-là les études de médecine
pouvaient être un lieu de compétition et
donc pas forcément un lieu de
bienveillance ou en tout cas où on pense
est-ce que ça vous parle quand vous
entendez ça tir hoselstein par exemple
euh oui c'est un élément que l'on
retrouve bien évidemment au cotidien
lors des études de médecine notamment
l'ex première année où il y avait un cut
important à la fin de la première année
pour l'internat également euh c'est un
élément qu'on retrouve également dans
l'enquête que nous avons mené j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure où cette cette no
notion de de de de communication de
formation pendant les études passe un
petit peu au second plan c'est pour ça
enfin très clairement c'est quelque
chose qui ressort c'est pour ça que nous
avons mis en place différentes
formations dans les établissements
hospitaliers notamment et notamment vers
les jeunes professionnels de de santé
qui sont souvent démunis je vais vous
donner un exemple très précis nous
sommes en train de monter une une
formation pour les jeunes
neurochirurgiens de la région Aquitaine
neurochirurgiens qui à l'heure actuelle
ont la plus forte pression médic légale
on en parle souvent de cette pression
médico- légale qui les perturbe quand
même beaucoup dans leur activité voire
même les conduit à refuser certaines
interventions bon et on leur explique
des règles de bonnes pratique pour les
rassurer pour les rendre un peu plus ZES
entre guillemets dans leur relation avec
les patients pour essayer de faire
baisser cette pression médico-légale
pour qu'ils exercent d'une façon
beaucoup plus sereine et simple et ça
c'est ce qu'on est en train de mettre en
place par exemple avec le CHU de
Bordeaux pierre est-ce que c'est un
sujet cette question de la formation
est-ce est-ce que il faudrait pas aussi
aller explorer de ce côté-là au-delà
évidemment des questions de moyens qui
sont évidents mais dont on parle plus
souvent là on en parle un peu moins de
cette question de la formation c'est
c'est un sujet qui est éminemment
important il y a eu un changement de la
formation infirmière il y a quelques
années il y a 10 ans environ on a
raccourci la durée de formation de 6
mois on était à 3 ans et demi auparavant
on est passé à 3 ans sur un cursus
universitaire effectivement sur les 6
mois on a perdu mais de tout temps moi
quand j'ai commencé ma formation il y a
11 ans maintenant c'était il fallait
environ 5 ans pour un infirmier une fois
qu'il avait son diplôme pour être inf
fermier en réalité euh 5 ans aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que c'est un ancien
parce que des 5 ans il y en a plus
énormément dans les services on a
surtout des des professionnels qui sont
très jeunes et malheureusement tous les
anciens enfin des gens comme moi je suis
compris comme un ancien maintenant sur
l'hôpital alors ça ne fait que 11 ans
que je travaille dans l'hôpital et je
suis déjà vu comme un ancien ce qui
prouve un petit peu la problématique
actuelle pierre chtellier je vais
revenir pardon sur la formation je
voudrais savoir si vous par exemple lors
de votre cursus vous avez été vous-même
est-ce que vous avez eu des modules des
stages des des moments d'échang sur
comment je vais gérer la souffrance de
l'autre la détresse de l'autre la mort
de l'autre l'appel à l'aide de l'autre
parce que c'est ça le quotidien des
soignants est-ce que vous vous sentez
formé à
cela vous dire ce que j'avais comme
impression de formation au bout de mes 3
années non très clairement non non non
on arrive sur le milieu professionnel on
passe d'un CAP on est stagiaire sans
trop de responsabilité puisque on est on
est supplayé un cap on a toutes les
responsabilités d'un coup et où la
communication d'un coup on est plus en
tant que stagia on en tant profess donc
il faut que notre parole soit vraie et
véridique donc là c'est un changement de
positionnement qui effectivement est
assez brutal et c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'avant il fallait environ 5 ans pour
un infirmier quand il arriv dans un
service pour être vraiment infermier et
comprendre toutes les tenant et pour
avoir justement ces formulations de de
communication et ne serait-ce que
reconnaître la communication quand quand
elle peut évoluer est-ce que c'est pas
une des énormes surprises en tout cas ça
a été la mienne agès Buzin qu' des
soignants ne soi pas formés à gérer la
détresse de l'autre ça va être ça leur
quotidien pendant plus de 40 ans
absolument en fait c'est une des raisons
des réformes des études de de santé
qu'on a mise en place c'est qu'en
réalité la la formation est très
disciplinaire c'est-à-dire qu'on apprend
au médecins mais c'est vrai pour les
infirmiers aussi euh la cardiologie la
gastrologie on a beaucoup de mal à faire
exister des formations transversal sur
des sujets d'importance alors il y a le
médico légal il y a la prévention et la
santé publique il y a l'empathie et
comment on s'adresse effectivement à un
malade notamment face à une maladie
grave comment on reçoit la parole de
l'autre comment on la TRA toutes ces
formations transversales on a beaucoup
de mal à les faire exister dans le
pourquoi pourquoi d'après vous c'est pas
assez technique c'est ça ne c'est pas
protocolaire ça prend du temps en fait
de changer les pratiques dans les dans
les facultés c'est vrai aussi pour les
écoles d'infirmières en fait les
praticiens qui viennent enseigner
enseignent leur spécialités et c'est
pour ça que toutes les écoles où il y a
maintenant des patients formateurs pour
les soignants ce sont des écoles qui se
sont mises en place dans un certain
nombre de facultés sont très utiles
parce que on oblige les soignants à
annoncer un diagnostic de grav de
maladie grave par exemple devant un
devant un patient et on attend son
retour pour s'améliorer toutes ces
pratiques sont en train de se mettre en
place ça prend du temps tout cela se
fait évidemment avec la bonne volonté
d'un certain nombre de doyen tous ne
voient pas l'urgence de la même façon et
ça nécessite évidemment des années et
des années pour former des générations
entières de soignants qui auront été
alertés à cela et puis c'est ce que je
disais au début il faut prendre en
compte l'usure du métier vous disiez
qu'il y a un turnover très important
c'est vrai c'est vrai pour tous ces
métiers de soignant avec beaucoup de
gens qui s'éloignent en réalité de leur
pratique au bout de 10 15 ou 20 ans
parce que c'est très douloureux de
prendre sur ses épaules la douleur des
gens la souffrance et la mort et un
moment soit on se blinde et on quelque
part un mauvais soignant parce que on n
plus dans l'empathie soit on reste
empathique et à un moment on n peut plus
soi-même et c'est ce qu'exprime un
certain nombre de personnes de votre
reportage Claude romau ça va changer
c'est en train de changer vous le sentez
vous aussi vous êtes mobilisé pour cela
et je crois qu'il y a une réforme qui
qui va seett il est évident que tout ça
doit être introduit dans la formation
initial de tous les professionnels de
santé les infirmières les médecins bien
sûr mais pas seulement donc ça c'est
c'est vraiment très important euh mais
moi je dirais pour compléter là-dessus
euh c'est aussi le système qui est
maltraitant euh déjà on laisse pas une
personne proche auprès de la personne
parce que comme on avait il y a 30 ans
en pédiatrie les familles s'embarrassent
ou posent plein de problèmes donc déjà
on pourrait laisser quelqu'un de proche
déjà on ne fait plus depuis longtemps
mais on va y revenir à de l'admission
directe pour les personnes âgées
lorsqu'un médecin traitant de ville
prescrit une hospitalisation on peut
faire faire confiance au médecin de
ville voilà il y a plein de choses
là-dedans et puis il y a le management
aussi et où il est où le top management
est-ce qu'on peut pas voir un peu les
choses autrement dans la l'organisation
des locaux certes on n pas les
professionnels on le sait des urgenties
il en manque des infirmiers des
infirmières aussi mais on peut faire des
organisations vous parliez de
révaluation des soignants juste avant
cette émission vous me disiez
normalement dans les mois qui viennent
ils vont être réévalués selon quatre
critères ça permet de revenir un peu
aussi sur la formation quelque part
c'est-à-dire que il y a depuis donc des
ordonnances qui ont été publiées
par sous le ministère de Monsieur
verrand et que on avait commencé les
travaux d'études du temps de d'agès
Busin d'ailleurs sur la recertification
des professionnels de santé tous les
professionnels de santé médecins
infirmière kiné tous ceux qui ont un
ordre professionnel devront recertifier
revalider leurs compétences tous les 6
ans d'accord 9 ans pour les anciens et
tous les 6 mais al la question c'est
est-ce que ce sont que les compétences
techniques ou est-ce qu'il y a comp
compétences techniques clinique la
formation continue le développement
professionnel continue qu'est-ce qu'il
font pour améliorer la qualité mais il y
a aussi deux autres axes qui vont être
pris en charge un qui porte sur la
relation au patients mais la relation
avec leur environnement professionnel et
au patients et le deuxième c'est
qu'est-ce qu'ils font pour être mieux
dans leur santé eux-même comment s pour
aller mieux eux-mêmes donc la santé et
le mieux-être évidemment et donc là on
est votre sujet il est en plein
là-dedans il anticipe un peu sur ce qui
va se passer mais il va être obligatoire
pour eux de rendre compte de ce qu'ils
ont fait comme action ou dans pour
améliorer effectivement leur mieux-être
et dedans bien sûr il y a la santé au
sens pur du terme mais il y a c'est
beaucoup plus là la santé au sens large
c'est aussi le mieux être dans le film
on a le docteur Émilie Tassin qui prône
là aussi dans la la lors de la
soutenance de son mémoire l'enseignement
des sciences humaines en mé
elle appelle à ça il y a un appel des
soignants teroselstein ils sont en
demande ils sont vraiment en demande
dans l'étude que nous avons mené c'est
quelque chose qui ressort également euh
on est parfois sur des enseignements
très techniques il le faut bien
évidemment sécuriser les soins
techniques mais on a aussi parfois des
difficultés euh dans la relation avec le
avec le patient c'est ce qui ressort en
priorité alors on peut mettre en place
on met en place des des des formations
de de ce type-là dans votre film quand
j'ai vu cette jeune conceur interne de
26 27 ans à mon avis dans ces ux-l qui
est sidéré face à une à la patiente qui
est jouée par un coach pour une
ordonnance c'est c'est c'est dramatique
et ce sont des des situations que l'on
voit soit à l'hôpital soit en soit en
activité de de de ville mais il y a
vraiment un effort à faire et nous nous
y employons pour en tout cas pousser
davantage de de sciences humaines bien
sûr et et vous avez bien raison de faire
référence à cette scène on va la revoir
on va en voir un extrait maintenant
parce que c'est un sujet qu'on a pas
encore évoqué vous avez un tout petit
peu abordé agès Buzin mais qui compte à
mon avis dans le mal-être des soignants
et la relation de soin c'est le
comportement du patient on en parle peu
moi j'avais pas vraiment non plus ce
sujet en tête quand j'ai commencé ce
documentaire et pourtant il m'a sauté
aux yeux quand j'ai assisté au cours de
Joceline rouer regardez un petit extrait
alors je viens vous voir pour une ERM là
voilà mon ostéopathe m'a dit que vit une
RM donc voilà j'en ai pas pour longtemps
je suis un peu pressée si vous pouviez
me faire l'ordonnance s'il vous
plaît
je
répond ça vous pose un
problème bah on va on va en discuter non
bah non non assdez-vous déjà non non
j'ai besoin de ça j'ai juste besoin
d'une
ordonnance alors moi j'espère qu'elle a
un petit peu exagéré pour le jeu drôle
mais a-t-elle exagéré est-ce que vous
pierre ch vous avez
déjà été confrontés à cette agressivité
des patients est-ce que vous la
constatez est-ce qu'elle est même de
plus en plus fréquente ou pas aux
urgences oui il y a de l'agressivité he
je en 2019 le collectif intergence il
s'est créé notamment à cause des
agressions qu'il avait eu à
Saint-Antoine donc l'agressivité elle a
été elle était présente est-ce qu'elle
est en majoration parce qu'on a vu avec
le collectif intingent c'est que oui
elle est en augmentation mais elle
s'explique par des causes qui sont très
claires c'est l'absence de médecin
traitant en ville c'est l'absence de
solution à l'hôpital c'est les temps
d'attente qui ont explosé au niveau des
services d'urgence et on estexcuse cette
agressivité de la part du patient vous
vous dites que ils ont des raisons
d'être agress j'excuse pas l'agressivité
mais je l'explique je l'excuse pas mais
je trouve des explications et c'est pour
ça qu'avec le collectif interurgence
quand on est parti en mobilisation à
l'origine on demandait surtout des lits
on demandait pas des des des gardes du
corps ou des caméras de sécurité onandit
vraiment des lit d'hospitalisation parce
qu'aujourd'hui la la question
prioritaire c'est quelle réponse on peut
avoir à la population et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que dans les services
d'urgence c'est extrêmement frappant
pendant 15 ans on a laissé la médecine
de ville dépérir parce que
financièrement parlant faut bien
comprendre que les services d'urgence
gagnaient beaucoup plus d'argent avec un
patient qui venait pour rien qu'avec un
patient qui nécessitait un soin
d'urgence donc les services d'urgence
ont laissé dépérer la médecine de ville
était très content que les patients
viennent consulter chez eux il y a des
services d'urgence qui se sont fait une
spécialité de faire de la consultation
rapide sur les tri et5 notamment à Bicha
où c'était vraiment venez venez donc
vraiment on sen voilà aujourd'hui qu'on
est en train de voir qu'il y a un
problème et compagnie on se retrouve àt
dans une situation où l'État enfin les
politiciens nous poussent à dire est ce
qu'on retrouve également au sein des
Urgences mais n pousse à dire à nous
professionnels que c'est de la faute des
patients qui viennent consulter pour
rien qui nous mettent dans cette
situation là donc on est en train de
nous mettre patient via soignant et
c'est ça que je n'aime pas du tout parce
qu'en réalité la situation c'est que
aujourd'hui ça va être très très dur
pour les patients qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant parceque aujourd'hui
les urgences ont changé leur modèle de
financement et finalement ces patients
là ben ne rapportent plus tant que ça
donc on va changer encore de modèle et
on va les renvoyer dehorsange de
paradigme on change de paradigme mais
juste la solution c'est que pour le
soignant pour pour le patient pardon bah
en fait là où avant il devait aller aux
urgences pour palier l'absence de
médecin traitant bah demain même les
urgences ne voudront plus de lui donc il
va se retrouver sans médecin traitant et
donc bah sans accès à la santé et c'est
ça qui va commencer à être très très dur
dans nos société qui va effectivement
augmenter les les risques de violence
envers les professionnels so les
relation énormément bon il y a
énormément de mesures qui sont mise en
place ou en train d'être mise en place
pour essayer de trouver justement une
façon de prendre en charge ces patients
sans médecin traitant et éviter aussi de
surcharger des urgences avec des
consultations de médecine générale il y
a énormément de choses il y a par
exemple l'entrée direct des personnes
âgées en gériatrie il y a équiper tous
les épades de télémédecine il y a créer
les maisons euh de de garde près des
hôpitaux où des médecins généralis
viennent prendre des gardes jusqu'à
minuit pour décharger les urgences en
fait il y a énormément de choses ce sont
des petites briques en réalité parce
qu'il n'y a pas de traitement miracle on
ne va pas créer des milliers de médecins
généralistes dans les 10 ans qui
viennent il faut le temps de les former
on ne va pas créer des milliers
d'urgentistes donc en fait ouvrir des
lits moi je l'entends évidemment le
problème ce ne sont pas les lits le
problème ce sont les soignants qui
n'existent pas et donc il faut il ne
faut pas s'arrêter au constat il faut
essayer de trouver les réponses
appropriées à ce constat elles ne sont
pas mir d'engager des médecins qui
n'existent pas sur une étagère ou
d'engager des infirmiers qui n'existent
pas il y a des milliers de postes
ouverts ils sont vacants et il y a des
milliers de postes aussi dans le privé
maintenant parce que le problème est
absolument partout pas seulement en
France et ailleurs et donc comment on
répond à ça et bien par des mesures
extrêmement précises ponctuell qui
répondent à chaque enjeu et sur cette
question de l'agressivité du patient
vous l'avez un petit peu effleuré tout à
l'heure cette question du consumérisme
de la santé est-ce qu'on est on assiste
aussi à un changement du côté des
patients qui auraient tendance à
consommer la santé comme si c'était
gratuit et qu'après tout c'était à leur
disposition je je pense que monsieur a
raison en disant que une part de
l'agressivité vient du temps d'attente
du fait qu'on ne trouve pas c'est cette
errance diagnostic et tout ça est réel
il y a aussi on le sait dans la société
je dirais un une exacerbation de la
violence en général elle s'exprime plus
facilement qu'elle ne s'exprimait avant
il y avait un interdit avant face aux
blouses blanches comme il y avait un
interdit face aux pompiers ou face au
policiers cet interdit n'existe plus
même vis-à-vis des blouses blanches et
donc tout ça est très douloureux pour
les soignants et puis il y a un
consumérisme c'est vrai qui a été
facilité et et c'est à la fois une
chance la télémédecine et à la fois ce
risque là c'est-à-dire qu'on sait que on
va aller sur Doct lib pour ne pas le
citer et trouver un rendez-vous en une
heure parce qu'on a besoin comme parce
qu'on a besoin d'une ordonnance et qu'on
l'a pas et donc en fait il y a il y a
toute un écosystème en réalité où chacun
doit prendre sa part pour essayer de
soullager cette agressivit c'est bien
pour ça que j'aborde la question du
patient parce que je pense
qu'effectivement claudambau il y a aussi
une pierre dans dans le jardin du du
côté des patients là oui mais enfin le
le patient c'est quelqu'un qui souffre
qui est angoissé
euh prenant les urgences et le milieu
hospitalier c'est extrêmement agressif
pour même si on est bien portant le
milieu hospitalier c'est donc l'angoisse
peut monter parce que on comme l'a dit
agè tout à l'heure l'errance
diagnostique est un véritable sujet donc
ils sont confronté à la dureté du
système donc effectivement on peut
comprendre que le patient qui n'est pas
le professionnel hein qui n'a pas eu
cette éducation on sait qu'il y a des
des trous dans la raquette en ce qui
concerne la relation et et apprendre à
se ressourcer les méthodes de dégagement
tout tout ce que vous avez montré très
très bien dans le film il y a de
multiples facettes dans dans ce
dispositif mais le patient il est pas
celui-là du tout il est dans son
angoisse donc il y a aussi le patient
qui est confronté je reviens au système
je pense qu'on a travailler là-dessus
comme disait agnè il y a de multiples
euh propositions qui sont faites mais
moi sur les épades je regrette on a
quand même un temps de retard pour
mettre en œuvre quelque chose de très
simple refaire confiance au médecins
traitant qu'il soit despades ou même de
ville comme on l'a fait un certain temps
d'ailleurs ne pas obliger les gens à
repasser par les urgences et et s'il
faut faire une admission directe on doit
pouvoir faire une addition direct mais
il y a la question des pourquoi les gens
les éepades préfèrent finalement envoyer
souvent aux urgences parce que si on
fait attendre la personne qui nécessite
des soins aigus que les épades ne
peuvent éventuellement pas fournir et si
on l'a fait attendre en hépate ça pèse
sur du personnel et qu'il n'est pas
aussi médicalisé qu'on veut bien le dire
donc voilà c'est c'est tout un système
qui qui est à revoiroselstein peut-être
un mot sur cette agressivité cette scène
là que vous vouliez vous-même commenter
elle vous a frappé a nous devons tout
faire pour continuer à prendre soin des
soignants c'est vraiment le le l'êre
motive euh moi j'aiété très surpris donc
par cette scène on l'a vécu de temps en
temps dans je pense dans notre activité
professionnelle de soins
euh par ailleurs quand on regarde le les
données du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins pour le l'année 2023 moi j'ai
été stupéfait de voir que quand on suit
une Corte de médecins primau inscrit à
l'ordre en 2010 et qu on regarde ce
qu'ils sont devenus en 2023 euh c'est le
le dernier bulletin de 2023 8 % de ces
médecins primoincrits ont disparu du
soin c'est c'est absolument bluffant on
se demande où sont passés des des des
soignants qui ont été formé pendant une
dizaine d'années alors qu'on manque de
de médecin donc je pense qu'il y a un
vrai il y a un vrai sujet de de ce
côté-là euh nous du côté notre mutuel on
essaie de mettre en place beaucoup de
formations et d'information mais il faut
un mécanisme beaucoup plus global pour
conserver les soignants dans le dans le
dans le soinin c'est c'est c'est
indispensable ce qui m'amène à cette
question de conclusion et je vous
demanderai de répondre relativement
rapidement comment améliorer cette
relation de soins s'il y a une une
méthode peut-être ou il y a pas de
solution magique comme a dit Madame Buin
c'est je pense que c'est une c'est un
c'est un changement total de dogme à la
fois du système de santé de sa vision et
de son de sa pertinence en fin de son
objectif et à la fois effectivement de
nos formations et même du système
interne hein je veux dire le le système
à l'intérieur de l'hôpital ou et est
complètement cloisonné on parlait du du
management oui vous a v réagir au moment
où Claude Rambo parlait de management le
management l'hôpital est tellement
cloisonné que si vous voulez aujourd'hui
vous n'aurez pas un cadre hospitalier
qui n'a pas été faisant fonction cadre
c'est-à-dire c'est queon est obligé de
formater la personne avant de lui donner
l'autorisation de devenir CAD donc déjà
le système n'évoluera pas en soit il est
bloqué il est déjà totalement gelé dans
l'hôpital et ça pour le changer
c'est très compliqué je ne sais pas par
où commencer très on a au moins lancé
l'échange ici c'est c'est un début
Claude rambau pour conclure pour
conclure je dirais que il faut aussi que
les prof elles comprennent et ça c'est
typique le dernier les dernières images
que l'on a vu que le patient évolue et
le patient est de plus en plus éduqué et
nous yveillons avec agès une de nos
ambitions à la Haute Autorité de santé
c'est de faire de patient qui soi acteur
de partenire partenaire coacteur j'ai
toujours dit coacteur et et ça ça n'est
pas non plus euh facile parfois accepter
par des médecins ou des infirmiers qui
ont souvent des positions de surplan par
rapport au patients et c'est-àdire voilà
donc il faut aussi qu'ils apprennent à
faire des questions ouvertes cette dame
elle dit je veux une IRM faites-moi une
prescription on n pas entendu de
questions ouvertes là-dessus hein bon
oui madame on vous entend pourquoi
voulez-vous une question une RM tout de
suite et voilà donc la relation elle il
faut qu'elle bouge mais ça passe par la
formation initiale et continue et
professeur corinisnard banis le dit
aussi à la fin du film le patient attend
moins aujourd'hui de la technicité que
finalement de
l'humain euh alors moi je terminerai sur
une note de confiance je pense qu'il
faut faire confiance aux soignants euh
quel qu'il soit un exemple euh vous avez
sans doute entendu parler d'une
initiative qui s'appelle médecin
solidaire
euh des professionnels de santé
consacrent une semaine de leur activité
qu'ils soi remplaçant jeunes médecins
retraité pour aller euh travailler dans
des centres de santé il y a deux centres
qui ont été créés en Creuse et ce qui
permet ce qui a permis à 3000 patients
de retrouver un médecin traitant c'est
une initiative de médecins qui décident
de consacrer une semaine de leur temps
dans dans une année et euh nous de
d'utre côté on a été très fier de donner
une amplification à ce ce mouvement ce
qui a permis à plus de 400 médecins de
s'inscrire et un 3è centre va
probablement être ouvert et je trouve
vraiment qu'il faut faire confiance aux
soignants la situation n pas simple mais
il faut leur faire confiance un joli
appel agès Buzin ou moi j'ai envie de
dire que la santé quand on s'engage dans
ce dans ce métier de soignant c'est
parce qu'on y trouve du sens
et souvent l'exercice solitaire et
l'angoisse qu'on a dans l'exercice
solitaire euh crée ce mal-être quand il
y a de bonnes équipes un bon esprit
d'équipe et notamment à l'hôpital euh il
y a moins de souffrance au travail et
justement ça améliore la qualité des
soins à la Haute Autorité de santé on
l'a vraiment vu euh ça faisait partie
des des des critères de qualité des
soins donc je pense qu'il faut recréer
cette ce collectif de soignants le
management actuel des hôpitaux souvent
du fait du manque de soignant met la
pression sur des rythmes
désorganise les équipes tout ça
participe à ce malè je pense qu'il faut
améliorer ce malagement interne et
puis faire confiance dans un système qui
est en train de changer tout était dans
la loi ma santé 2022 simplement le covid
quelque part a tout arrêté dans cette
transformation on reprend maintenant la
transformation 3 ans après mais à terme
je suis sûre que le constat étant bien
posé les problématiques étant bien
posées il y a des solutions pour chacun
de ces problèmes de l'espoir pour
terminer cette émission merci beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup ça merci à vous merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi comme
toutes les semaines à très bientôt sur
public Sena
[Musique]
merci